欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们第十一章我们来讲一下关于平台流量的结构以及如何去布局我们的店铺
这里面主要是讲一些具体的思路
这些实操我们可以根据我们之前所学的方法去进行操作就可以了
因为我们先把它的结构及它流量的来源如何去分析这些思路都会了
那么我们把之前学过的方法用起来就可以了
那么通过这节课我们能够知道平台的客户从哪里来
它又跑到哪里去了
如何让客户留下来
这些都是我们重点去关注和重点需要去做的事情
这节课是非常重要的
我们一定要重视起来并去操作
那么接下来我们来讲第一个小节
就是关于流量结构的
通过流量结构的分析
同时我们根据店铺里面我们各个流量板块
哪个部分流量少来找到我们
店铺里面能够有增长空间的一个渠道
我给你们看的这个图就是关于整个平台的流量结构
当然这个图不是绝对的准确
但是它能够告诉你我们店铺以及平台
它当前的一个流量结构的一个分布情况
那么这些比例
比如说自然流量占比还有付费流量占比推荐流量占比
这些比例都是会变化的
所以说它不是永久固定的
那么我们要学的是什么
我们要学的是平台会从哪些端口给我们的店铺进行导流
比如说自然流量是包含榜单导购还有就是新品
还有就是会采购直播短视频这些都是涉及到的免费流量
知道了这些是免费流量之后
我们应该去做什么来获取这部分的免费流量
是不是我们就知道我们可以做很多事情
针对榜单我们要怎么样去做
针对导购会场我们怎么做
针对新品怎么做
针对这个会采购怎么做
直播和视频怎么去做
我们之前是不是也讲了很多相关的方法
告诉大家怎么样去做呢
一定要知道这个之后
我们才知道我们需要做什么是吧
第二个就是付费板块
你看付费板块主要是自动车
自动车里面就有两种板块
一个是付费搜索流量
一个是付费的推荐流量
大多数情况下我们主要是做的是搜索流量为主
推荐是在流量短缺
或者是说你店铺里面的人群标签比较精准
产品的许盘质量非常高的时候
我们可能就会去采用推荐进行一个推广
获取更多的流量
那么你看顶展
梦顶年框超级名片
还有明星展位这些等等
都是属于付费流量
所以我们就要知道我们在平时用的工具以及操作的方向
都偏向于哪一种
那么这个就有利于我们去判断
我们是可以从哪些维度还可以增加我们店铺流量的
最后一个就是推荐流量
比如说平台的首页
猜你喜欢
每个行业的首页猜你喜欢
产品详细页
有产品推荐
买家资付发布寻盘的一个列表都会有一些产品的推荐界面
这些都是推荐流量
所以这些板块一定要重视起来
你要知道整个平台哪里有流量可以导入你的店铺里面
那么你就更加清晰你要去做什么事情了
那么这个就是关于平台流量的结构
我们可以通过这个结构来找到我们流量增长的巨大
那么如何找到我们店铺里面需要增长的流量呢
比如说我们店铺里面
目前的自然流量跟付费流量的占比
比如说是付费流量占比80%
那自然流量可能占比20%
那么这种情况是不是我们要想办法提升我们的整体的自然流量
降低这个平台的一个付费流量
那么是不是才有可能降低我们的平台成本
和整个店铺的运营成本
这边增这边就会降
因为它加起来是等于百分百的
所以这个就是我们判断的一个标准跟依据
你要知道它是这么样的一个逻辑
是有公式计算的
所以你就会知道要做哪些维度去提升我们店铺就可以了
那么下一节课我们会详细讲解这些里面的一些重要的板块
我们只讲几个比较重要的板块
其他的那些板块你可以按照自己的思路去看就可以了
比如说这些我们就不讲了
你就可以去按照我的这个框架去学就可以了
那么这些我们之前也讲了
其实也没有必要去详细的讲解了
那么这一个板块在直通教板块也详细讲解了
这里就不展开来讲解了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再继续关于这个板块的内容